Speaker 1: I want to talk about two things we've
talked about many times before, but not together.
And those two topics are, on the one hand, anti
and pseudo intellectualism and on the other hand,
the covid-19 pandemic. Now, covid, of course,
we've talked about for a year and a half every
week. And sometimes even more often, we've tracked
cases, we've tracked deaths, variance masks,
vaccines and everything in between. We've
also talked about anti intellectual and
pseudo intellectual movements. And that's a really
big topic. And this goes back to the genesis of
American intellectual ism in the eighteen
hundreds or even arguably earlier than that.
But it also includes simply an analysis of people
who read books by by authors like Tucker Carlson
and Bill O'Reilly. And they start to think that
they're educated and they have a well-rounded and
nuanced and detailed view of how the world
works and the belief that one is much more
informed than they actually are. But these
two issues, anti intellectual ism and covid,
are very much linked. There's a really good study
in Nature that was published a few months ago
called Anti Intellectual ISM and the Mass Public's
Response to the covid-19 Pandemic. And when I was
looking through this recently, I realized
that many of our previous discussions about
anti intellectual ism apply perfectly to what's
been going on with this pandemic in the United
States. It applies to mass squaring. It applies
to anti vaccine sentiment and to so much more.
And the article does a number of different things
to assess how people came to believe incorrect
things about the pandemic, be it about the virus
itself or about public health measures or vaccines
or whatever else. And the conclusion is not
going to be a surprise. The article finds, quote,
We provide evidence of a consistent connection
between anti intellectual ism and covid-19 risk
perceptions, social distancing, mask usage,
misperceptions and information acquisition,
very, very much not unsurprising finding. So
there are actually two sides to the people that
still won't get Maxin vaccine. Hated that still
think masks don't do anything, who think the virus
is fake or whatever part of it is that they are
part of a political movement whose leaders spent
basically all of twenty telling them this isn't
very serious. We don't need to do anything,
open everything. The economy is what matters
most. That's part of it, which is politics,
plain and simple. But the side we haven't talked
about as much as the anti intellectual ism, a
distrust of scientists and doctors, a distrust
of authority, feeling that they know more,
much like Trump always felt that he knew
more than his generals or doctors or whoever,
because they read whatever it was on Facebook or
because their uncle told them whatever it was.
Now, you might say, well, that anti intellectual
view is based on their politics. So it really is
still politics. And I would agree with you,
but these are still two distinct but related
phenomena. And then the last piece of this that I
want to discuss is that the anti intellectualism
and the rejection of science is very post-modern,
which these right wingers claim to be against.
Now, of course, most of the right wingers who
talk about postmodernism don't have an iota of
a clue, not even a scintilla of an idea of what
postmodernism is. But to the extent that they sort
of understand it, right wingers claim to hate the
postmodern idea that they say exists on the left,
that every narrative is equally valid. Every
opinion must be given the same consideration
as every other. And I'll tell you what,
I'm also against that. I've talked about
my opposition to that idea that every narrative,
every idea must be given equal consideration.
But those very same people are furious that
they're anti vaccine misperceptions, that
they're covid conspiracy delusions aren't being
given the same weight, the same consideration,
the same seat at the table as what medical doctors
and public health officials and science says.
It's truly the height of hypocrisy. So we have
yes, we have a political movement that spent all
of last year saying you don't really need to worry
about this. And that's a big factor. And then,
yes, we also have this anti intellectual,
pseudo intellectual component of people who,
because they looked at Facebook, think that they
know as much as or more than the public health
officials. But then the third layer on top of
it is the incredible hypocrisy of being against
the culture they believe exists on the left
and it exists in some enclaves of the left,
although I don't think it's predominant that
every idea must be given an equal seat at the
table. But that's exactly what they want and what
they expect with their ideas about vaccines and
masks and whatever else. And they become furious
when social media platforms or elected officials
or whoever say, hey, you know what? What you're
saying just isn't based on science. So we don't
need to give it equal consideration.
It's hypocrisy, placenta antionette
anti and pseudo intellectual ism, plus the
politics of the Republican Party around the virus
in twenty twenty. Let me know what you think. And
is there something missing from that three layered
analysis? I would love to hear from you and add to
it in a future segment. We are getting very close,
my friends, to the 16th anniversary of The
David Pakman Show. August 16th is that day,
the 16th anniversary of The David Pakman
Show. To celebrate, we will be doing a one
day membership special. If you've been listening
for one, two, three, four, five, six, six years
and you've occasionally thought I kind of like
this, maybe I'll support it in some way. The
perfect day to do it is August 16th. If you want
to get an email telling you how to take advantage
of our 16th anniversary discount, just get on my
mailing list at David Pakman Dotcom. Remember that
this program yeah, this one, this one today
is mostly made possible by folks like you who
get memberships at joint Pakman Dotcom. Com, I
encourage you to grab such a membership. You'll
also get instant access to the daily members
only bonus show an extra show every single day.